pyong yang février 2005 on fait moins 20
degrés dans les rues de la capitale nord
coréenne
sur la place centrale cela fait plus de
trois heures que tout le monde attend le
coup d'envoi officiel des cérémonies
impression surréaliste pas plus tard que
la veille le régime de kim jong-il le
président de la dernière monarchie
communiste de lacaune est annoncé pour
la première fois au monde entier
posséder l'armé nucléaire
mais personne ici n'est vraiment encore
au courant du changement de discours
aujourd'hui c'est la fête nationale le
jour de naissance de notre cher
dirigeant tout joue
cette saison le jeune universitaire se
sont rassemblés sur la place qui mixe
nous dansons pour célébrer son
anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
notre guide lui a reçu le feu vert pour
parler du sujet le plus ta vie du pays
c'est aussi une première en corée du
nord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier le ministère des affaires
étrangères a déclaré que conformément
aux principes et aux défenses nous
possédant l'armé nucléaire et que nous
la dévotion
pensez vous
de la gombe des américains
non de la nôtre visiblement nous ne
sommes pas les seuls sur très vite une
autre faut qu'il enchaîne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
c'est tout en haut
[Musique]
on s'occupe des avants
matteau mais qu
heureusement pour elle notre
interlocutrice choisis au hasard dans la
foule
recouvre assez vite et mon réflexe
politique jamais aucun souci
nous avons à la tête de notre armée de
faire notre cher dirigeant kim jong il
nous devrons pas nous attaquer même si
les oiseaux ils ne connaîtront pas la
défaite face à la résolution de la pri
dirigeant kim jong il et de notre armée
de faire
avant la crise nucléaire nous avions
obtenu l'autorisation exceptionnelle de
sillonner pendant 12 jours le pays au
départ en voyage organisé par le
ministère du tourisme pour promouvoir
les richesses culturelles
les naturelles du pays
première étape de notre périple une
ferme très particulière à une heure de
pyongyang
[Musique]
hélas le val s'accouple avec deux
semaines oui un mal cette taille
alternativement avec deux femelles
qui mangent des autruches en corée du
nord
il travaille il vient de par la volonté
de notre cher dirigeant bien aimé est
l'avis réservé en priorité aux bugs
travaux elle estimé dans tous les
restaurants tu nous l'exportons
également
je mange tous les jours la viande
d'autruche je mange aussi leur maman
j'ai 22 ans d'abord je vais me consacrer
à la mission que m'a confiée notre
général kim jong-il faire se reproduire
des mille ans suit je me marianne
au cours de la visite des abattoirs
flambant neuf de la terne nous allons
avoir une surprise de taille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les équipements de moss abattoirs mai
2002 transformation
de société française
et ici il n'ya pas que les machines qui
sont françaises
[Musique]
cure des autruches et solide et souple
on est tous ces grands motifs naturel
très original il y a beaucoup de
demandes
lorsque nous avons commencé l'élevage
les rails nous avons visité la maison
hermès et nous avons étudié leurs crocs
dina
des faux sacs hermès fabriqués dans une
usine nord-coréenne grâce à des machines
françaises et ce au nez et à la barbe de
l'ambassadeur de france en corée
finalement contrairement à nos craintes
notre présence fortuite à pyonyang en
pleine crise nucléaire arrange les
autorités
c'est pour eux une occasion rêvée de
sensibiliser les occidentaux à leur
point de vue monsieur feu
a même re suivant
petits plats dans les grands
[Musique]
oui
landes du
[Musique]
canada
avec tout ça en fera
ok
[Musique]
ça c'est sûr
ce sens de l'autriche
incroyable profusion de nourriture dans
un pénible la famille concerne des
centaines de milliers de personnes
tout le monde mangeait faut viser qui
avait pas manger mais là c'est fini on
trouve à manger partout nettement
avant de mourir chez nous et croyez
kennedy est maman d'un entraînement mais
lors du retour
[Musique]
on
évite le triste où les touristes
étrangers de venir se tait
[Musique]
ça fait combien
quatre heures on compte 80
[Musique]
matchs et
80 euros pour ce festin l'équivalent de
six ans de salaire moyen en corée du
nord et bien sûr ici une pub de 10 en
clair seuls les étrangers et les membres
de la nomenclature à tout accès à ce
genre
[Musique]
au détour de la conversation monsieur ce
nous explique la nouvelle doctrine
politique du régime
l'industrialisation happart a confessé
la pacification avec les faire de
musique aurait là que les petites zones
clp
pour l'été qu on a la primauté à l'armée
salah la puissance notre économie ne
peut pas se développer
[Musique]
la primauté du point de vue de l'armée
sur tous les autres pour en prendre la
mesure il faut aller à pas mon job un
passage obligé en corée du nord c'est la
zone frontière l'avant poste avant la
corée du sud et les 35 soldats
américains qui font régner le statu quo
entre les deux pays depuis 1953 le
discours ici naturellement belliqueuse
mais cette fois l'officier chargé de
nous recevoir à ordre de jouer la
séduction la solidarité entre l'europe
et particulièrement la france et la
corée du nord
il ya trop à faire ici on savait qu'à
la salon de réception à côté à une offre
sur les courts
le gouvernement débouche
costil envers notre pays nous retirer
internationale à l'énergie a selon
qu ils
m'ont dit big guy
fabriquer des armes nucléaires
blonde bien entendu nous ne voulons pas
la guerre
est-ce qu'il pense que les américains
vont attaquer la corée quoi comme ils
ont fait avec l'irak
il dit que vous avez raison c'est que
nous n'avions pas fabriquer des armes
nucléaires ce serait comme en irak ca c
40 années d année car je suis content
j'ai compris
votre tour si la côte à nyon et de dire
à monsieur chirac de venir ici passer
ces travaux l'agrasc
frites aux
[Musique]
voix ce sherlock de venir ici
au fil des jours la crise entre la corée
du nord et les états unis s'accélère
pyongyang aurait déjà six bombes
nucléaires en sa possession un essai
nucléaire serait même prévue au mois de
juin
peut-être mais peut-être ne s'agit-il
plutôt que d'un grand bluff des
nord-coréens pour forcer washington
pékin mais aussi tokyo à leur donner
plus d'être nancière comme ils le
réclament en vain depuis des mois bien
sûr nous n'aurons pas accès à la
centrale nucléaire de pyongyang
la visite de cette centrale électrique
présenté comme un bijou de modernité
laisse perplexe quant aux réelles
capacités technologiques huppé
[Musique]
à l'issue de cette centrale électrique
façon sûre il ya de monde
dans cette centrale est logique nous
fabriquons 225 ans le roi de pharos les
fournissent l'électricité à tout en lui
assurant le chauffage est
déclarée
osa
album ces données ou l'orangé le foie
chez l'homo
on a
faut dire
[Musique]
sur le mur on peut lire sur cette
pancarte il faut bien maintenir les
équipements après un an de produire plus
d'électricité sans acception signé 15
janvier
[Applaudissements]
avant de quitter le pays nous aurons
aussi le droit de filmer le grand
barrage de nampo l'essentiel de
l'électricité produite en corée du nord
vient de là
comme on ne tiendra qu'à
vous allez dire que ce barrage le
socialiste a porté ses fruits côté
années sont colossaux
son propos
des fruits
légende suivant le résultat du social en
scène
il
existe des coréens nis du bâti ils en
seraient informés
et disait un seul ou de l'assassinât
du leader on jouait pas si le peuple à
chacun de notre côté sentimental en
termine avec le même succès soudain
le vide est
le triste étrangers ap les enregistrer
notre crise ils sont unanimes à dire que
vraiment c'est la création monumentale à
travers
ce barrage
[Musique]
en nous avons pu connaître la puissance
de la corée du nord et puis et les
succès de celui-ci réalisé par le peuple
coréen
grand moment de solitude pour notre guy
monsieur ce après 12 jours passés à
répéter inlassablement le même discours
lui aussi aurait bien besoin de quelques
jours de repos
[Musique]